last year the buccaneers had three
quarterbacks tom brady and blaine
gabbard with ryan griffin on the
practice squad ryan griffin's biggest
contribution was to serve as the guy who
kept brady from falling over drunk after
the boat parade when they won the super
bowl now they have kyle trask second
round pick fell to them there was a
thought that he would go higher than
that there at the bottom of round two
they actually thought about taking him
at the bottom of round one so they got
him a full round later here's bruce
arians talking about the development of
kyle trask
it's not easy when you're going against
our defense yes he has seen a multitude
of blitzes and coverages so i'm really
impressed and
you know it's uh you know when having
worked with guys for the first time in
this offense
he said he's at the top of the list as
far as the learning curve and uh and
he's throwing the football really well
mentally wise he's not far behind but
andrew did in the same offense and
you know it's um
what andrew did that year is
unbelievable but
i'm not saying he's andrew luck but
but mentally he's
mentally he's really really sharp
bruce erins loves him some hyperbole not
long ago he was calling blaine gabbard
the most underrated player in the entire
nfl
really
they they have an issue there brady
trask gabbard griffin yeah somebody's
got to go and aaron's talked about that
yesterday he's not ready to call griffin
the odd man now griffin's been there
since 2015. crazy 2015 well it goes back
to one thing he's played in two games
2019 he's played in two games but uh i i
i can't imagine them keeping four guys
around no i'm with you you know and you
know that it goes back like the griffin
thing goes back to like the same cop
he's a non-threatening perfect backup
quarterback you know the team's never
going to walk off the practice field and
go whoa did you see our back up they
might go they might go whoa did you see
our backup holding our quarterback up
straight so he doesn't make a fool of
himself
uh weakened at bernie sanders
he still made it full of himself it kept
him from falling down and busting his
face well yes either way i loved it i i
i i thought it was great that was great
i agree you're right right but like i'm
with you with the i think ryan griffith
is the the odd man out i do yes i mean
blaine gabbard has the experience you
got a super bowl team you got to keep
him as the backup and trask has a chance
to be the future i mean that's why they
drafted him and i think it's encouraging
all those things you hear you know from
from bruce arians trask
from his college tape to his pro day
did
pretty drastically change his throwing
motion in his body which is very
encouraging you know bruce arians likes
big quarterbacks like big ben you know
peyton manning even brady you know
carson palmer those are big guys trask
is that kind of guy
and that's where he fits and we'll see
maybe they really struck gold here in
late in the third round and found the
future but he's got some time to develop
behind the great ones
i'm still not a big believer in guys
changing their throwing motion for their
pro day and having it stay with the new
motion when it's time to go play
football the biggest example there tim
tebow remember all the talk in 2010
always change his motion yeah his
emotions are fine when he starts playing
he's going to go back to that slowly
cranked catapult motion and we saw that
time and again but
look arians has made it clear not that
long ago
that he's staying he's not going
anywhere there was a report super bowl
sunday he may retire if the buccaneers
win and he called that bs although he
used the full word
uh
he's staying until brady goes and he
made it clear recently he would be happy
to stay afterward that's when he said
blaine gabbard he'd love to work with
him most underrated guy in the nfl he's
got kyle trask now and
it it's kind of the
belichick brady
conundrum on a different level
because aryans is going to want to prove
that he can still coach at a high level
without tom brady when brady comes in
and does so much for your team and
everyone thinks oh it's brady it's brady
it's brady i think ariens is going to
feel compelled to stick around and show
that he can be successful without brady
yeah it'd be interesting to see i mean
certainly brady got you know the the
the the the you know the majority share
of the credit this year that's for sure
you know but it got bruce erin's a super
bowl he doesn't care we'll see we'll see
if he can kind of check his ego at the
door with with that whole conversation
as we go forward but i like i don't
expect him to retire anytime soon now i
mean damn he's worked all this hard and
now he's finally he's got a team that's
set up for the next three or four years
to be one of the best teams in football
so he's like damn i'm not giving that up
i'm gonna stay right here and see if i
can't squeeze another super bowl win
maybe two out of this but you know you
bring up an interesting point there that
you know maybe that reality could start
to be an issue at the end of this season
and next off season
but i think that if you are aryans
you've put in the work you've paid your
dues you got your first opportunity
that's right head coach late in your
career because you don't kiss ass you
don't play the game you are true to who
you are it's one of the reasons mike
zimmer had to wait as long as he did so
why now
when you've put in the effort when
you've reached your spot why would you
walk away from that that's right that's
right question came up earlier this week
about roger goodell how much longer
he'll be the commissioner be the
commissioner as long as you can right
die with your boots honor tell you guys
get the hell out yeah that's the point
you're making huge money you've cracked
the code on the job why would you stop
doing something that you have put that
much time and effort into
perfecting and reaching a level where
it's working yeah it's working that's
right and it's easy for you now or at
least easier than it's ever been why
would you stop doing it so yeah aryans
coach as long as you can goodell
commission as long as you can or
commission or whatever the right word is
and uh that's the way to do it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports